welcome back to CBS mornings Congress is
considering new rules for Airlines after
severe air travel disruptions ruin the
holidays for tens of thousands of
Americans there's a group of senators
who now want to enshrine a passenger
Bill of Rights into law and at least one
Airline CEO says the industry must start
making changes our Chris Van Cleave is
at Phoenix's Sky Harbor airport in
Arizona Chris good morning
good morning David Southwest Executives
will face some tough questions from
members of Congress later this week but
already some are calling for expanded
consumer protections for U.S Flyers
similar to what Travelers in Europe
already have
with their daughter Emily in a Denver
Colorado Hospital over the holidays
Christine Pasteur and her husband booked
a Southwest Airlines flight for December
26th to be with Emily on her birthday at
the airport they learned their flight
was canceled and it would be days before
Southwest could find them another flight
we were devastated we were playing this
trip for quite a while and the most
frustrating part is that it was blue
skies all the other airlines were flying
and there were seats available and we
just could not get there the pastors
were among the hundreds of thousands
stranded during Southwest meltdown
resulting in nearly 17 thousand canceled
flights costing the company about 800
million dollars now several U.S senators
say Airlines need to do more to protect
consumers the goal is to level the
playing field for consumers they're
being ripped off Senators Ed Markey and
Richard Blumenthal introduced an airline
passenger's Bill of Rights aimed at
requiring Airlines to fairly compensate
Flyers during Airline cause delays and
cancellations the Senators also want to
limit fees for bags seating as well as
for changes or cancellations this is the
Department of Transportation is planning
new regulations to prohibit charging for
families to sit next to Children if
passengers could receive 1350 bucks
whenever their flight is delayed by four
hours
I am guaranteeing you there'd be a lot
fewer delays Airlines for America the
trade group representing most of the
nation's carriers says it is in the
interest of all U.S airlines to provide
a positive flight experience for all
passengers the proposed policies in this
bill would drastically decrease
competition leading to a subsequent
increase in airfare prices if you try to
run your airline like you did in 2019
you're going to fail we sat down with
United CEO Scott Kirby in January before
the proposed legislation was announced
he says United is already changing how
it operates leaving more crews and
planes in reserve while investing in
technology upgrades in an effort to
prevent A disruption from becoming a
crisis we flew a lot less in 2022 than
we would have liked to because we had to
give ourselves breathing room to invest
to build up Staffing buffers to get
everyone through training and just to be
prepared for growing up for the future
right now you're doing less with more so
that you can do the less better yeah so
putting customers first and that means
you have to do us and you need more
resources to do the same thing because
that gives you the resilience
Kirby believes that will be a model for
the rest of the airline industry the
pastors tell us they're still waiting to
hear from Southwest if they'll be
reimbursed for more than 800 in expenses
from that trip they were never going to
they never were able to take Southwest
says they're still processing some of
those requests the airline has
apologized to customers says it is
investing a billion dollars in upgrading
its I.T to prevent situations like that
from happening again David Chris
passenger Bill Wright sounds good to me
thank you sir